ce film est définitivement à un autre
niveau,
je veux dire fermer Las Vegas Boulevard,
c'est vraiment très excitant, nous avons obtenu la
permission de prendre le contrôle de Las
Vegas pour fermer le Strip là-bas, le
premier film qui a réellement
fermé une si grande partie de Vegas  le film
culmine à Vegas avec notre meilleure
poursuite en voiture et j'aime sentir que nous en avons fait de
très bons, nous essayons de faire plus d'
accidents de voiture uniques que vous n'aviez pas vus
auparavant, nous avons l'atout et Bourne et
ils sont  se pourchassant le long de la
bande créant un carnage les voitures que
nous conduisons c'est un véhicule SWAT et
la voiture de police donc il y a beaucoup de force
et d'énergie qui seront exposées
Je me tenais juste au milieu de Las
Vegas Boulevard c'est énorme comme  Je
ne peux même pas comprendre l'
ampleur de ce que nous faisons, je suis toujours là,
le plaisir de ne pas vraiment croire que je faisais
partie de ce film moi-même, c'est un grand
film de Jason Bourne plus grand que nous
ne vous avons jamais fait